-Fox News has apparently barred
its own anchors from covering
a billion-dollar lawsuit
against the company
that revealed
its on-air personalities
knowingly lied to their viewers
about the 2020 election.
Meanwhile, Fox also gave airtime
to Marjorie Taylor Greene
to defend her call
for a national divorce
between red states
and blue states.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
You will often hear those
on the right say
that the so-called elite
corporate media lies
to its viewers, although, I
personally find it a little odd
that they complain
about the media
being corporate elitist
when their favorite network
has a giant headquarters
in midtown Manhattan
and is owned
by a mega corporation run
by a media mogul who is one
of the world's richest oligarchs
and the main villain from the
second "Crocodile Dundee" movie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Australian accent ]
Yes, I can see that's a knife,
nut I'll tell my viewers
it's not a knife.
Who do you think they're going
to believe?
[ Laughter ]
Now, obviously,
I'm not going to say
the media never
gets stories wrong
or that you can't disagree
with them.
You can,
as Senator Bernie Sanders
did recently,
without even saying a word.
-We also have one of the most
innovative healthcare systems,
when it comes to creation
of pharmaceutical drugs.
[ Laughter ]
You are doing this.
-Bernie --
[ Applause ]
Bernie uses his index finger
the way a samurai uses a sword.
[ Laughter ]
If he raises it,
he has to wag it.
[ Laughter ]
You know, by law,
he actually has
to carry a license for it
and keep it in a tiny,
little holster.
[ Laughter ]
What I appreciate about Bernie
is that there's just
no guile with him.
It's the opposite
of a Jedi mind trick.
If Bernie had been in that
cruiser with C-3PO and R2-D2,
the scene would've gone
much differently.
[ As Sanders ]
These are, in fact,
the droids you're looking for,
but I'm not going to let you
take them, and here's why.
The top 1% of stormtroopers
already have 99% of the droids.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
But there is --
there is a massive difference
between criticizing the media
for limiting the scope of debate
and claiming journalists,
as a whole,
are engaged
in a broad conspiracy
to lie to people,
as Bernie explained.
-Do you worry, when you talk
about the corporate media,
that you are targeting
journalists when you say that?
-No, no.
Donald Trump talks
about fake news
and that's simply
to deflect attention
from the fact that he's
a pathological liar.
My experience,
one-on-one with media,
they work hard,
very rarely am I misquoted.
But what I am talking about,
Margaret,
is that corporate media limits
the kind of debate
that we have in this country.
-Mm-hmm.
-You tell me. You know more
about it than I do.
How often do we talk about
income and wealth inequality?
-We're talking about it
right now, Senator!
-Yeah, but how often?
Not everybody has Bernie Sanders
on your show.
[ Laughter ]
-And, you know,
Bernie will go on any show,
if you're willing to let him
talk about income inequality.
Bernie would fully do
"The Masked Singer,"
if it meant...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...getting his message out.
[ As Sanders ]
Bravo. Good guess.
But now, the bad news.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is,
there's a difference
between good faith
media criticism
and claiming journalists
are engaged
in a nefarious conspiracy
of lies,
as the right often does.
In fact, as it turns out,
they're the ones
knowingly lying
to their viewers,
as we found out
from a recent court filing
and a billion-dollar defamation
suit against Fox News.
-A stunning new court filing
revealing how top talent
and executives at Fox News
trashed Donald Trump
and ridiculed his legal team
and their 2020 election
conspiracies behind the cameras,
all while hyping those
same conspiracies on the air,
to their viewers.
-Fox staff were privately
blasting the Big Lie as BS
and saying, "mind blowingly
nuts," "reckless."
-As Trump lawyers Rudy Giuliani
and Sidney Powell
were making wildly false claims
about rigged voting machines
after Trump lost in 2020,
private communications reveal
that pro-Trump voices
at Fox News
were calling it nuts.
"Watching Giuliani!,"
Rupert wrote in an email...
...Tucker Carlson wrote
to fellow Fox host
Laura Ingraham.
Ingraham responded...
...said Fox host Sean Hannity...
They were all
communicating privately
about how insane
the Big Lie was,
while turning around and hyping
that lie to their viewers,
When I first read those quotes,
I was honestly speechless.
I just wish I had a way
to communicate
my disapproval without words.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
[ Applause ]
Senator, please,
put that finger back
in its holster!
[ Laughter ]
You know, when he's
over my shoulder like that,
he looks like the Angel Bernie,
telling me not
to do something bad.
[ Laughter ]
Angel Bernie,
should I lie to my viewers
and tell them Trump
won the election?
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
Oh, that must mean there's
a Devil Bernie on my other side,
telling me to go for it.
Let's see.
Devil Bernie,
should I lie to my viewers
for ratings?
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, this is what happens
when we take a week off.
[ Laughter ]
We lose our focus and we have
two Bernies onscreen
at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
The point is the very same
Fox News anchors who constantly
accuse the so-called
mainstream media of lying
were themselves lying
to their viewers
and were admitting,
behind closed doors,
that they were lying
to their viewers.
And the supposed evidence
they were getting
for all these claims
was transparently insane
on its face.
-Before one interview with Trump
lawyer Sidney Powell,
in advance, she told Fox
that her single source
for these election claims was
a person who does
"time-travel
in a semi-conscious state."
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Let me repeat that.
Their source, now at the heart
of this defamation claim,
at a time when the lies led
to violence,
was someone who said
they knew what they knew
because they got it
by experiencing
"time-travel
in a semi-conscious state."
[ Laughter ]
-If Sidney Powell had
a time-traveling friend,
why didn't they tell her
turtleneck sweaters were
out of style?
[ Laughter ]
Fun fact -- Sidney wore that
outfit at the press conference
where Rudy's head started
to leak.
You guys remember that?
[ Laughter ]
A day professional hair
and makeup artists
now refer to
as their Pearl Harbor.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Of course, Rudy doesn't use
professional hair
and makeup artists.
[ As Giuliani ]
I save so much money
when I do it myself.
[ Laughter ]
"Um, Rudy,
one of your eyes fell off."
[ Laughter ]
Double-sided tape, my ass!
And can I say, if Fox News
had a time traveler,
I always thought
it would be Rudy.
I mean, look at him.
He always looks like
he just got back
from the year 3,000.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, in Rudy's version
of "Back to the Future,"
he travels back in time to make
sure his parents never met.
[ As Giuliani ]
If they never marry,
my first wife
won't legally be
my second cousin.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, but,
Rudy, if they never meet,
you'll never be born."
I'll cross the bridge
when I come to it.
[ Laughter ]
But that's right --
Fox aired an interview
with a crazy person
who told them, in advance,
that her only source
for her election fraud claims
was someone who supposedly
time traveled
in a semi-conscious state.
Was there any follow-up?
"Man, Sidney, it would help
if you had
a second source here."
[ As Powell ]
I have a haunted antique doll
[ Laughter ]
who sometimes speaks to me,
but sadly,
she's pretty convinced
Biden won fair and square.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, she's being
a real bitch about it!
[ Laughter ]
My favorite part of that time
travel story, by the way,
is that the Fox anchor
who received that information
then passed it along
to the Trump family.
-Not only did they air that,
but the host,
Maria Bartiromo,
welcomed that lawyer Powell,
knowing that she had
this made-up conspiracy theory.
And then that's not all.
The Fox anchor then
steps in as a conduit
to take that information back
to Trump family members,
responding to the lawyer Powell,
that she shared this important
"info with Eric Trump."
-Man, if there's anyone
in the Trump family
[ Laughter ]
who would be excited
to hear that time travel
is real,
[ Laughter and applause ]
it would be Eric Trump.
[ As Eric ]
Thank you for sharing
this important info, Maria.
I will use it
to travel back in time
wearing a mask
of my father's face,
to have a catch
with my seven-year-old self.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think that will fix
everything!
I will also intercept
and replace that birthday card
he once gave me that said...
[ Laughter ]
Why does Hallmark
even make those?!
[ Laughter ]
The lawsuit also alleges
that Trump himself tried
to call into Fox on January 6th,
but that Fox refused
to put him on-air,
presumably because they knew
what he was saying
was dangerous.
According to CNN...
[ Laughter ]
That is the most polite
euphemism I've ever heard.
[ Laughter ]
That's like Hannibal Lecter
describing himself
in his Tinder bio as a...
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, Fox knew this was all BS
and yet, they were hiding it
to their viewers, anyway.
In fact, they were even trying
to punish others at the network
who dared to correct the record.
-When Trump falsely claimed
that Dominion machines
cost him 2.7 million votes,
Fox reporter Jacqui Heinrich
responded
with a tweet saying...
Some of Heinrich's
colleagues at Fox
wanted her to be punished,
even though they knew that
what she was saying was true.
...Tucker Carlson wrote hosts
Laura Ingraham and Sean Hannity.
-So, next time Tucker rails
against corporate media,
remember, he does the news
with one eye
on the stock ticker.
[ Laughter ]
He's always checking
on Fox's stock price,
as well as his other
investments,
like the Bow Tie Emporium
and [Bleep] M&M's.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But...
Tucker isn't news.
He's entertainment
and he knows his audience
doesn't want the truth.
They want their stories.
Tucker Telling the truth
would be like Kylo Ren
turning to camera
mid-threatening monologue
and saying,
"I'm not really Kylo Ren.
I'm Adam Driver.
You guys know me.
[ Laughter ]
From 'Girls.'
None of this is real.
It's just for fun.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, back to 'space.'"
Fox viewers didn't want
the truth then,
and they don't
want the truth now,
which is why no one on Fox
is talking about the lawsuit.
Yesterday, one of their anchors
said on-air
that the company had told him
he couldn't cover the lawsuit,
despite his strong objections.
-Some of you have been asking
why I'm not covering
the Dominion voting machines
lawsuit against Fox,
involving the unproven claims
of election fraud in 2020,
and it's absolutely
a fair question.
I believe I should be
covering it --
it's a major media story --
given my role here at FOX.
But the company
has decided that,
as part of the organization
being sued,
I can't talk about it or write
about it, at least for now.
I strongly disagree
with that decision,
but as an employee,
I have to abide by it
and, if that changes,
I'll let you know.
-So, Fox is censoring
its own anchors now.
What's next, are they going
to replace Sean Hannity
with that Microsoft chat box
that started going haywire
on everyone?
[ Laughter ]
What are they going to do,
program it
to say the word woke
over and over?
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome to "Hannity."
Tonight's top story --
woke LEGOs are taking over.
Woke M&M's, woke textbooks,
woke Potato Head,
woke Dr. Seuss.
Woke, woke, woke, woke,
woke, woke, woke, woke.
[ Laughter ]
And yet, none of these
revelations seem
to have changed anything
over at Fox.
They're still doing
their usual thing.
Just last week, they gave
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
extensive airtime to explain
her unhinged call
for a "national divorce,"
which, she said, would separate
red states from blue states.
-I don't see middle ground
on a lot of these issues,
so, what is the other answer,
if it's not a divorce?
-Well, exactly, Sean.
That's the problem
and where we are today.
And, in my life, in my world,
all of my friends
are regular Americans.
Everyone I talk to is sick
and tired and fed up
of being bullied by the left,
abused by the left,
and disrespected by the left.
And our ideas, our policies,
our ways of life
have become so far apart
that it's just coming
to that point.
-And do you expect it'll happen?
Last question.
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I think it's something
that we should work towards
because, you know,
it's kind of the vision
that our founding fathers had
for America.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-A national divorce?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Greene ] A national divorce
was the vision
of the Founding Fathers!
I know because I time traveled
in a semi-conscious state
and talked to them.
[ Laughter and applause ]
How about this?
Instead of a compromise --
This will be the compromise --
instead of red states
getting a divorce
from blue states,
America gets a divorce
from Greene.
She's definitely dressed for it.
Remember when she showed up
to the state of the union,
screaming at Joe Biden
in a white fur collar,
like she was demanding sole
custody of the Maltese?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Greene ] You hand over
Clarabelle right now!
[ Laughter ]
I'm the one who fed her organic
chow and put bows in her hair!
[ Laughter ]
The Dominion lawsuit
has exposed, yet again,
that the people
who constantly accuse
the rest of the media of lying
are themselves the ones
who knowingly lied
to their viewers.
They took their cues from,
among others,
a guy who always looks like
he's about to...
-Time-travel
in a semi-conscious state.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]